From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I have to do a little quick introduction.
My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop. We are in St. Augustine, Florida.
Today is Tuesday, the 13th of September 2011.
We are at the Bayfront Hilton in St. Augustine to do a series of interviews related to local civil rights history for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of American History.
John Bishop, I think we are not recording to the X-T cards.
Okay, we have those back. Do you need me room tone?
No, we are okay. Any other housekeeping?
No, I think not. Okay. We're delighted today to be able to sit down with you, Miss Duncan.
Our interview we is Miss Gwendolyn, a net Perkins Duncan.
And we will talk about local civil rights history and her involvements that are ongoing still even today.
Thank you very much for your generous willingness to sit down and also your flexibility, because I know we've had to juggle our day today.
So thank you for that.
I can ask you just to, and I think we'll probably spend about a half an hour together so we can kind of pace ourselves that way.
I wonder if you can start by talking a little bit about your family and how it situated here historically in St. Augustine and how you've all had your various involvements in the movement and its legacy.
I'll start off. My name is Gwendolyn and I was born and raised in Lincolnville of St. Augustine, Florida, June 28th, 1956.
I am a fifth generation native, my great grandfather, my great-great grandfather, Thomas A. Finley, lived in St. Augustine and in Lincolnville.
I was told that he moved from the Carolinas. It took many years for them to get here and I used to often wonder from a child, why would they come so far to St. Augustine?
What was the driving force to leave this family to come? Finley is a certain name to St. Augustine. And later in life I learned why.
But my great-great grandfather had 13 children. Some were born along the way coming to St. Augustine in South Carolina, Georgia, and eventually he ended up in Motri, which is just south of St. Augustine, St. John's County.
I was told that we did the research that he had about 13 acres and was a farmer. His daughter, which was my great-grandmother, Abby Finley.
She married a human, Abby Finley, and she bought some land in Lincolnville. The St. Augustine record which did not mention black people often made mention of his 89th year old.
He died at 89 years of age and they said he served the white community well. That was in the newspaper. We all just said, we were what he was, he brought his wares from Motri to St. Augustine, the city of.
And eventually moved in Lincolnville with my great-grandmother. She was a founder of St. Sipper and the Piscobal Church, which has been in Lincolnville for maybe over 150 years now.
My mother's grandmother, Elizabeth, I know it was Abby. She lived right directly across from the church, which they built.
And still, you know, they have a congregation right even to this day. It was fun growing up in Lincolnville. Things were segregated.
But, you know, as a child, you really didn't know what segregation was all about until you venture it off in downtown areas.
But growing up in Lincolnville, like I said, it was great. There were many businesses along the way because of the segregation.
You know, you had your own grocery stores. You had the beauty parlors. There were bars along the street on Washington Street.
There were, had newspaper publishers. You know, everything you need it was in Lincolnville. And the church was a center of activity.
They had the church socials, picnics, everything centered around the church. And I am one of eight girls. My mother had eight girls, no boys.
And so I guess it was kind of, you know, the house was situated for women. And young girls, not my stepfather, who was only a man in the house, but a hard working man.
And I thank the Lord, you know, for my great grandmother. I knew her. She died at probably about 89 or 90 years of age as well.
She died before my grandmother, my mother's mother died. And she died in November of 1963. Same month that President Kennedy was shot. I can remember that happening.
But I know you want to talk about the civil rights movement. What I remember most from a child at seven and a half years old when Dr. King came to St. Augustine was the marches by the Ku Klux Klan.
From a child's point of view, every dress through Lincolnville, from a child's point of view, and you didn't know what was happening.
You thought it was some big parade that you wanted to participate in. You know, it was just, you know, it was a parade to me.
But I can recall, you know, at night, there was a time of terror. And I remember one night in particular, I guess all the black people came out.
I was a little child, but I can remember, you know, black people lining the streets in the Ku Klux Klan marching through the area.
And we went down on the corner of the Haven in Central Avenue, which is now Martin Luther King Avenue. And we watched the marches march through our area.
And I can remember, as we were walking home, my mom holding my sister's hands in mine, and she said, don't look back.
I could just remember the terror of don't look back. Keep walking. And some of my classmates, you know, at Excelsior, some of their homes on the other street were bonned, fire bonned.
But I can remember something sticks out in my mind about a bad cop. And I used to think that bad cop furniture store, they were bad people.
But it was like this bad cop I would hear from a child's point of view, bad cops. You didn't trust the bad cop, you know.
And I remember one morning, you know, my mom was on the porch. She was coming here. And Dr. King must have, he was staying across the street to Mr. Proctor's house.
And I don't know if he stayed there that night. All I know is he came across the street to ask my mom if she was going to participate in the rally or to marches that night.
And that I used to always think it was like a faded memory. I asked my mom when I got older. Did that actually happen because I remember it happening, you know.
And she said it did, you know, you know, you have these faded memories, you know, you have to verify.
But as I grew older, that's about 10, 11, 12 when you had to venture off downtown. That was the only time I really experienced, you know, this segregation going into the store.
And people watching you like you, we're going to take something or steal something. And I can remember the, because everything was in walking distance downtown was not far away.
It was less than two miles, less than a mile. But I can remember the doctor's building in Flagler hospital was around the corner.
And the doctor's building on trimmer's in street, I can remember a colored sign being up on the wall when you walk through the front door.
And as you, it was right to the right. I mean, I can see that sign even now. But the memory is I can also, you know, remember it coming down.
But we would have to go to the right and go around to the back of the doctor's office. And there was a straight hallway when you walk through the door that you could not tread.
And I was always wondering what was down that hallway, you know, that's the way I wanted to go. But the sign, the colored sign pointed to the way that I should go.
But I can remember that sign coming down. And although they painted over where that sign was, the spot where it was was still, you still could see the spot.
So when it came down, I thought, you know, and I took my sister, one of my younger sisters to the doctor, because my mom, we were working in my stepfather as well.
But I had to take her to the doctor's office because although I was a second from the oldest, I was giving a lot of responsibility, I guess, because I was, my mom always said, beyond my years.
And I remember I said, well, the sign is down. I'm going to go straight down this hallway, which was forbidden before.
And I walked down there and my little sister and we ended in the doctor's office.
And everybody looked at you as though you had a communicable disease. You know, when you walk through that door, I can just remember that feeling.
But I went to the front, put my name down for my sister as she needed to see the doctor and we sat down.
And to my surprise, they called us first. And I thought, oh, great, we won't have to wait that long.
But then they marched us back through that office back to the backside where we used to come in the back.
And if I followed your time and correct, if you're 10 or 12 at the time, this is well passed, of course, the passage of the Civil Rights Act.
This is 66, 67, 68.
Yes.
Yes. I couldn't remember the exact year, but I do remember the sign when it came down.
As I grew older, you don't understand from a child's point of view what is happening all around you.
Yet I remember being in the fifth grade and I completed my fifth grade year at Excel C Elementary School.
And in the sixth grade, we had to go, it was forced integration. So our school closed down and we had to go to our street school.
And I could recall the teachers not wanting to teach you.
You know, it was in the kids not wanting to sit by you.
But I felt good about myself because I was not, you know, I guess I had some good self-esteem.
And I was a smart, you know, the braggest fact.
You know, I was a smart child. I probably would have been valedictorian if the school's remained black, you know, or salutatorial of my class.
But I can remember going to be in force to go to the schools and we had to fight.
It looked like it was a non-violence. We had to fight even to eat, you know.
The teachers didn't want to teach you.
And you felt a sense of a second-class citizen which I never felt being in the area of Lincolnville when it was segregated, you know.
But I didn't like that feeling.
And so even through our teen years going to the junior high school, the junior high school didn't even have a cafeteria.
So you had to walk back to Orange Street just to eat.
And the white kids were form a line, you know, to prevent you from going to eat your lunch.
So it was a lot of violence back then. I remember in the teens, you know, in the junior high in the high school.
It wasn't non-violence. You know, people were fighting.
Just fighting just to, like I said, just to eat lunch, you know.
Because you were not wanted and they made you feel that way. You were not wanted at those schools.
But Lord Blessing, you know, we were able to get on and graduate even through Sinagasni High School.
But you still felt that atmosphere of not being a part of the city in which you grew up in.
My kids experienced it too, you know.
And there is an atmosphere still here in this town.
Mrs. Cara Johnson refers to it as like a hidden vapor, you know, over this town.
But I think the Lord for the Twins, I think the Lord for Dr. Heeland, I learned about him later in life as I grew up.
And there was an opportunity after one of my friends, Mrs. Catherine Twine died.
She would tell us bits and pieces about the civil rights movement.
And I felt that because I lived through it, you know, the signs being up and they coming down.
But David Nolan, after her internment in 2002, he and JT Johnson from Atlanta, Georgia.
Jane Billings of Brown, she was a professor at one of the schools. I think it was Spellman in Atlanta.
David Nolan, as I said, Mrs. Cara Johnson, Dwight.
I can't remember his last name. Dwight Hines, I believe it was.
Sandra Parks, they all met at a restaurant.
South Seas over on the island.
And they discussed the upcoming 40th anniversary of the civil rights movement of Sinagasni.
And David Nolan, who is a local historian, asked me to put on my thinking cap.
They come up with some ideas of how we could commemorate or celebrate this event.
And so when I got that email, I told my husband about it.
And he said, we'll help. We'll do what we can. So I emailed him back.
And I said, whatever you want me to do, I'll do it.
I said, we can base this celebration, this commemoration on a family reunion.
And invite all these people who have participated in the movement back to Sinagasni.
Because in 2001, we had a family, our first family reunion in which we invited people from all around the country,
you know, back to Sinagasni for a family reunion.
And David Nolan took part in that.
And I just want to mention too that we found one of my daughter did genealogy research.
And we found one of our cousins who was the ambassador of Medagascar under President Clinton's administration.
We found her all the way over in Africa, Medagascar to Allen on the side.
But it was such a wonderful time, a joyous time.
Until I thought that would be a great thing to invite these people back to hear their stories,
their incredible stories of their participation.
Because as we learned about the civil rights movement, we know a lot of them left the city.
So Miss Cara Johnson and I set up a meeting at the Gallimor Center.
And we put it in the paper and invited people to come for a strategic meeting to see if there was any interest in, you know, having this commemoration,
which was to take place in a couple of years.
And we were amazed that older people came out and they began to share their stories.
There were incredible stories.
Some of them were heart wrenching stories.
Some just, I mean, it was just tear jerkers hearing what the terror that these people went through doing that era of the civil rights movement led by Dr. Healand, Dr. King.
And so from that meeting on, we decided we're going to just bring these people back to St. Augustine and invite them and sort of can tell their stories and, you know, just get together.
And not necessarily have a joyous time but commemorate and remember and recognize what happened in St. Augustine because it was, it was hidden.
It was hidden by the power structures in Augustine who didn't want to acknowledge that something like that ever happened.
I remember one meeting we had at, it was on the Soto place.
And J.T. Johnson would come in and he flew in from Atlanta. We invited him to come.
And there was a demonstrator sitting in their audience and he said, why don't you all let sleeping dogs lie? Why bring this up again?
Just leave it alone, let it go.
And J.T. Johnson stood up and he said, it's just time to just say thank you.
And that struck me even to this day and we just wanted to say thank you.
We wanted to bring these people back and just say thank you for the sacrifices that you made for us.
I know it probably was disappointing, you know, to some of them who fought so much, you know, to make life better for the next generation and generations after to come back and see things had not changed much here in St. Augustine.
St. Augustine at one point didn't appreciate its black history.
I learned later in life that the first free black settlement in the United States was Fort Mosaic, you know, and that may be know why my ancestors came so far and risked so much that come to this place of sanctuary because it was a sanctuary for blacks at one point.
Things have changed. They're not the same even now and it makes me want to cry.
It brings people tears to know that all that Dr. Haley fought for, all that Dr. Martin Luther King did here in this town, there's something still remain the same.
But, and I will wipe my tears away, I am so thankful, I am so grateful for the sacrifices made by these people.
I want them to know that the sacrifice was not a vain for me. I have five children, excuse me.
I have five children and we stress education that they must get a good education in order to survive in this world.
But I have a son, Zebra Lendonkin, who graduated with the engineering degree from the University of Florida, industrial engineering degree and systems engineering, got a bachelor's degree.
And he came back to this town seeking a job and could not find a job.
He was even qualified to treat, to teach geometry, trigonometry, all of these high math courses, but he could not get a job in this city.
So he went back to school and got his bachelor's degree and building and construction and still couldn't get a job in this city.
He wrote something that really touched my heart not too long ago and put it on online that the city that he loved will never be the city that he will come back to ever again.
And this has been, this has been an norm for a lot of black people here in this city.
I'm just going to tell the truth about it.
Sin Augustine needs to change and the change is going to come and I don't know who's going to make those changes.
Maybe be the young people who come back to make changes here.
But about the civil rights movement and the 40th accord, it has been a pleasure.
It has been an honor these last eight years to bring recognition and honor to these folks to enlighten the public about what happened here.
The struggles that these people faced just for the basic human rights.
I just thank God our organization, the 40th accord, there are no paid employees. Nobody gets paid.
And for a number of years, we weren't even funded, you know.
But in the Northrop Grimm incorporation, thank God, they decided to give us a chance and they funded 30 historic civil rights markers in and around the city.
And I thank God that some of the city officials allowed this to happen and some private citizens offered and gave us permission to put these markers, these historic markers in their yard to tell the stories because there are many, there are numerous stories of the sacrifices made by just local citizens and those who came from afar, you know, to help with this movement.
And I'm just glad to be a part of bringing recognition to people like Dr. Robert Haley, the Synogoctynful, Aginel, it was in Joanne Anderson, Elmer.
We have a lady who's a hundred, she'll be a hundred and seven years old this year who gave her name is Mrs. Reena Ayers, who gave lodging and food to the many demonstrators who came from the North, to attorneys who came from the North to defend them in the courts.
And it is our hope that this knowledge of this American history is known not only in the United States but afar as well around the world.
So if anybody watches this 50, 60, 70 years from today, they'll know that there was some great people that walked among us, angels I call them.
And their sacrifices will not go in vain.
And I want my children to know about it, my grandchildren to know, I want everyone to know what happened here in St. Augustine, Florida.
Let me ask you kind of a hard question, which is, what are the things that haven't changed that are the problems now as you line them up and see them in the city around you?
There are not a lot of jobs and opportunities for blacks here in St. Augustine.
If you went up and down the streets, you probably wouldn't even find, you probably count on your hand the black businesses and I doubt if one hand would cover it.
There was a loss of jobs.
If one hand wouldn't cover it, probably.
Yeah, one hand probably wouldn't cover those jobs. I mean, you know, those businesses.
There's not a lot of blacks in the city government. It's not a lot of blacks even in any type of administration and power here in St. Augustine, to me, in St. John's County.
And a lot of people have just left the city. The young people have left and I don't know if they will return.
Like your son.
Like your son, as well.
But he doesn't live that far away. He's right over in Jacksonville. And his wife is a professional, an internal medicine.
She has a Indian internal medicine. I have a daughter who has a doctorate degree in physical therapy.
But she's here in St. Augustine. She has a job now, but she's looking to go elsewhere.
She just came back here a few months ago from O'cala, Florida. And she's thinking about moving to her wife for a little while and, you know, just seeing the United States.
But if we can get job opportunities back here, I think there would be a change made in St. Augustine.
Tell me, I'm interested in the reaction to the placement of the Freedom Trail markers.
And the range of reaction, maybe, is the right way to ask the question.
Well, they're like, as the ambassador, young said, they're like, weeds growing up.
I guess the atmosphere now is better than it used to be. I couldn't even say two or three years ago.
There is a demand to know about the history.
There are tourists coming in asking about the civil rights movement.
Some didn't even know it was a movement here. When they heard about it through, I guess, Crossin in St. Augustine and Ambassador to Young did, that brought a lot of recognition to the movement.
Some didn't even know Dr. Cain even came. But I think now with the new city manager, you know, the attitudes with Ambassador Young come in that attitude has changed a little bit.
And I guess once history that was covered up by the city is now being embraced because they see, and I'm thinking, because it's the money maker, you know.
And I believe the dollar is the revenue that can be generated is the driving factor.
Do you think now?
Do you think that that's ultimately the calculation that motivated the city's willingness to place the trail markers and the
foot soldiers monuments rather than a more sort of a deeper moral transformation? I mean, I know you can't really know the answer for sure, but
Well, the foot soldiers monument, that was a private venture.
Yeah.
I mean, the city took credit after it was, you know, the money was there.
But at least they sort of, if they weren't welcoming, at least they didn't do what all that they could have to stop it from happening.
I can say that, I guess.
I think the wheels were turned in and it just wasn't going to stop.
Yeah.
I mean, people were going to keep coming, you know.
And like I said, a lot of people that gave us permission were private citizens to put those markers on in their yards.
Right.
But the city, I guess attitudes have changed somewhat.
And, you know, with the ambassador young coming back here and previewing his movie, that, that, I mean, really thanks took off after that.
Just more exposure.
Yes, very much.
It was a national exposure.
How do you evaluate the motives of Northrop Grumman?
Well, you know what, I just, I'm going to attribute that to just God's blessings because I have wrote a letter to the management there asking for funding, you know, to help with this commemoration, the recognition services that we were having.
And it fell in the right hands.
That's what I say.
And Lord, just blessed, and it opened up their hearts because the history shows that Fertile Hill, the company that was previously there, they were not very friendly to the civil rights demonstrators or blacks that were employed there.
And I, I trivited to the people coming from the North.
You know, the attitudes were not the same as those that were here in the South.
We're back after a brief, just a very brief pause to change recording tracks.
Okay.
I'm just talking, let me ask you for, you've been so patient to accommodate our crazy schedule today.
And the, the, the history runs so broad and deep, it's, it's hard to, to have just a relatively small amount of time.
But I want to ask you, are there other things when you tell this story and help people understand St. Augustine, other things that we should spend some time talking about themes, episodes, incidents?
Well, St. Augustine, I'm telling you, it is a great little town. I mean, I always thought it was a wonderful place to raise a family because it's quiet.
You know, if the big one being in New York City, you know, just visited, I would not want to raise kids in, in, in New York City.
St. Augustine was a, is a quiet town, a peaceful town. But as, uh, Hank Thomas said, it is paternalistic.
It's so, we need caring for, you know, as, so we can't take care of ourselves, you know.
But, um, it's a tourist town.
And, um, we need to bring some more industry into the city.
I could see the city of St. Augustine remaining old and, you know, historic, but the county itself needs to open up to industry where people will come back.
And blacks will be, it'll be a place that they can come, raise their families, like it used to be.
I would like to see it like it used to be.
It was good growing up in Lincolnville. It was good growing up in St. Augustine. And there were thousands of black people here.
They have just taken flight out of this place. And I think something needs to be done to draw the people back.
What's next for 40th accord?
Well, we have, um, an upcoming speaker. We always commemorate the anniversary of the Signing of the Civil Rights Act.
In this past July, we had Dr. Dorothy Cotton come. She was our keynote speaker. And I guess speaker was Sonja Plummer.
She was a granddaughter of one of the Civil Rights activists here, Reverend Goldie U-Banks.
She comes July 2012. We have, uh, Arthur Taylor Branch coming.
That's, that will be our signature event. The, uh, and we do freedom trail tours from time to time to educate the public and tourists who come who want to know about the history.
And you help, you help, uh, with the whole series of, um, materials and training for school teachers?
Yes, we've done two workshops in the, uh, we got, got permission from the superintendent of schools and we did two workshops for the Teachers of St. John's County.
And it was wonderful. And we had one at St. Augustine High School. Dr. Helen was a speaker. We had brought in Miss Lillian, Twine Robeson.
Uh, it was numerous speakers to share their stories with the teachers. We put together a, a workbook, um, of civil rights activities, pictures, documents for the teachers.
The first year, an author of Grumman funded it and the, I guess two years later, we did it again. And we put them on, you know, the, the workbook on the CD.
But funding has been an issue, you know, for the 40th of cord and getting programs done because it wasn't a popular subject.
And we saw it State Federal, you know, CD State and County Federal funds, but never were approved. If it wasn't for the author of Grumman, you know,
the story would not have gotten out. So, um, but our, I guess our long term goal is to establish a civil rights museum here in St. Augustine.
That is, is not just the 40th of cord. We have, uh, the 40th of cord started an organization, uh, I guess a committee.
And we had a meeting and they decided to come up from under the umbrella of a cord because it's such a big adventure.
And we have the chairman, Richard Burton out of Jacksonville, who was a national NAACP board member. He's our chair, JT Johnson Co. Chair.
We have the, um, President Flagler College on that committee, the mayor's on that committee. And, um, we're looking by 2014 to have something up and running.
Not the multi million dollar facility that Ambassador Young has, uh, great hopes of raising funds for, but something to celebrate and commemorate the 50th anniversary of the Civil Rights Act in St. Augustine.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, it's just been a great honor and privilege. I really want to thank you. And, um, it'll be really great to watch all those plans move forward. So thank you for all that you've done and all that you're doing.
Thank you.
And thanks for joining us today. Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.